The Joe Rogan experience.
Sometimes I feel like all these problems are put there for a reason than
anything.
Oh,
you're so cute.
I know reason.
No,
no,
I just.
Anything is anything a solvable including that happens,
happens for a reason.
When that stuff is all annoying.
It's annoying,
but then it's not right.
I'm with you.
I believe what you're saying.
I believe.
I believe it's anything.
Any human beings do incredible things,
man.
Just come up with.
Do you ever hear the story about Morse Morse code like that was the most
revolutionary is the turning point in history more because if you think about
it,
Alexander the Great.
Who was 18,
20 when it was invented?
I think I hit it when the first time they actually,
I think it was 18,
19 years and when the first time they actually had a 10 mile stretch of of wire
and the guy was able to send a message and before that,
think about this.
Before that,
the the guy,
the guy before 18,
whatever,
18,
15,
he had to send a message the same exact way.
Alexander the Great did either on horseback,
either on foot or either by boat.
Okay.
And when Morse code came up and Morris was a guy who was a really,
really successful painter,
okay.
And he had nothing to do with electronic magnetic fields or anything.
He was a really successful painter.
His wife,
he gets what we get to a letter that his wife is very sick.
He loved his wife in Connecticut.
By the time it gets there,
she's not only dead.
She's been buried and he said,
this got to be a way I can get information faster because it killed them.
It was this tragedy.
Seven years later,
he's on a boat.
He meets this electromagnetic engineer.
He starts talking to him.
He gets fascinated with the idea that maybe I can come up with a way to use
electromagnetic fields to send a message.
About 10 years after that,
he invented something called Morse code.
This painter,
because he was so heartbroken over his wife and and by the end of the world has
never been the same.
That was a bigger communication leap actually than the Internet because it was
the first time we were able to send instantaneous messages,
uh,
and,
and I think five years later we finally had a wire from New York to New Orleans,
which was so much faster and you could get instantaneous communication in the
world was never the same,
and of course we built on that,
but there's the history,
so full of individuals that we're trying to solve a problem that seemed
insurmountable and oftentimes it was because they basically.
I'm like,
Alexander Fleming had a cold.
He,
he,
his snot fell in.
He had all these petri dishes working on different sports and stuff,
and he,
he decided to clean stuff out himself.
He never used to clean his own petri dishes.
He had a cold,
is snot fell into one of the moldy dishes and he realized that the bacteria
under the microscope,
the mold that killed all the bacteria and he went,
wait a minute.
That's how he invented a little something called penicillin,
which then became antibiotics,
which is why people are alive.
It's crazy.
So many.
So many of these things either happen through accident with individuals or
people were trying to solve a problem.
Yeah.
This is.
That's one of the things about life is that you need struggle.
It seems like you shouldn't have it,
but you need it.
I'm reading this book by Jon Krakauer called under the banner of Heaven,
which is about fundamentalist Mormons.
Do you know about this?
No.
Woo.
Holy Shit.
Is that like the Jeffries Guy?
Yeah,
there's A.
I think so.
The jeffries,
which was the Jefferies,
Jefferies Guy,
was the guy that just got arrested.
He was the polygamists.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
So here's the way it works.
There is in this book it talks about,
I can't remember the town,
but there is an area that is run completely by a guy named Uncle Ruan or was run
by this guy named uncle rule on who is a mormon fundamentalist.
This.
These are these people are rejected by the mainstream Mormons because the
government came in at one point and said,
you guys can't be polygamous.
It's illegal.
And so they had to renounce polygamy,
and this was something that,
according to this book Joseph Smith said,
was the essence of mormonism.
It's still one of the most deepest,
most important parts of mormonism is that you have multiple or what they call a
plurality of wives.
Plurality.
That's good learning.
So,
and here's the thing,
this is why you need a bunch of wives.
If you are a fundamentalist Mormon,
you are only supposed to have sex with your wife when she's,
Oh,
oscillating.
Which means if you only have one wife,
you're not only going to have sex a few times a month,
once a month,
I don't know,
a women late once a month.
If you have 15 wives you can fuck every night.
So it's very important to have as many wives as possible because then you could
have sex with them all the time and they're always humping.
And a lot of these guys have so many children that one of the,
I can't remember which one it was,
it might have an uncle ruin.
I can't remember which one had so many children that they named them according
to the year.
So if you're a born in like 1979,
you are your name would have an a,
so it'd be like Annabel Angus Ra and then you would know what year your kid was
born in by the first letter of his name.
That's how many kids are having.
So then you have girls and your girls get to be the age of 14 and you've got a
pow like vita 14 year old kid and I was a fundamentalist mormon.
I'd be like,
Joe,
why don't you marry my daughter Laurie?
She just started bleeding and then I would give her to you and you would
immediately start fucking her.
And so that's what they're doing out there is like.
It's just like just herds and packs of pregnant teenagers that have been
impregnated by these older dudes who have so many wives and this shit is.
I think it's still going on today,
man.
There's whole communities dedicated to this polygamist lifestyle,
which is a lifestyle that Joseph Smith said was one of the most important
aspects of mormonism according to book.
The other thing about Joseph Smith,
do you know what he did before?
He found he founded mormonism,
what he was,
what was called like a treasure seeker,
and so you would use magic stones to peer through to that would show you where
secret treasure was buried and he.
There was a huge lawsuit against him because he convinced all these people that
he could find.
That was also what he said about the golden tablets.
That was a seer stone and see it through a magic rock.
That's how he could read the golden tablets before he was doing the seer stone
and the Angel Moroni before he's using the seer stone in Angel Moroni came to
him.
He was actually getting work convincing people like,
hey look,
I've got a magic rock and there and I can find your silver for you.
Because there was like a guy who hired him because he knew that there was some
silver hidden up in the hills somewhere and Joseph Smith went around with boards
through the courts and finally after like three months of hiring and by the
month they took him to court and they're like,
hey,
this guy can't really find treasure with that.
Rock
me.
Well,
he's out there looking every day.
Wouldn't you have loved to seen like a video of him talking of Joseph Smith,
like talking and explaining his strategies and what he does and what mormonism
is all about?
Yeah,
man.
I mean I just love.
I just love that idea of like
that.
Here's a man who was.
Look,
come on.
Let's just admit it.
Here's a man who's like,
just basically like a classic con artists come on man class.
Really telling people you can find treasure with a rock.
No one's ever found treasure.
That's something like when I was in the third grade that I would lie about to a
kid in the playground or something,
but this guy was making money off of it.
It's just very interesting to see something grow roots and flourish in the way
that that mormonism has.
Just with a very simple investigation ended the.
You've got lawsuits.
There's written records against Joseph Smith because he was taken to court for
lying.
Oh Shit.
Itunes or recording to server.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Server.